so there will be an election is what I'm
saying the votes will be counted and
then just like 2020 there is going to be
widespread dispute here's why I don't
think there's going to be people in the
streets because there weren't people in
the streets during covet so Americans
what are you talking about yeah
the BLM people what I'm saying is a lot
of these the lockdowns and the and the
pushback was far less than if you had
set us all down I think everyone in this
room and it was 2019 and you said all
right if these state governments are
going to make it that you're not allowed
to leave your house for two weeks for
basically for a lot what a lot of people
think is no reason are the American
people gonna stand for this or is it
going to be violence we would have all
said they're never going to be able to
get away with it but they did so I I
disagree okay let me hear you so why did
people Riot like crazy all over the
country we we joke we call it the 529
Insurrection now on the surface the
media says black lives matter but as
we've discussed in great detail the real
reason people in New York are rampaging
through the streets was because they
were locked inside and they had gone
insane